so I'm Tom Lucas and I mean independent
producer and I'm going to talk about
another kind of information that'll kind
of take us in a different direction and
that's a scientific data and more
difficult to access but potentially
impactful to the user so as a producer
of films about science over the years
I've seen that numerical simulations as
an example are becoming more and more
part of the science toolkit alongside
theory and observation so I got a
glimmer of this in the 80s when we did a
film about tornadoes for Nova and there
was a thunderstorm simulation and it run
performed on a Cray supercomputer and it
was crude but still produced realistic
storm features so it's kind of a
breakthrough so things have gotten a lot
more sophisticated since then and the
clip up here gives you a little bit of
sense of a contemporary storm simulation
and it was developed for another we
developed for another know of a program
called hunt for the super twister and
Margaret was in on one of the screenings
and hope she remembers it fondly so this
is just a one-minute clip inside storms
dynamics means how the individual blobs
of air all interacting with each other
to produce the flow that becomes either
the strong winds or even the tornado or
even though things that produce hail
based on years of weather research Lou
produces an amazingly detailed computer
simulation designed with scientists at
the University of Illinois it reveals a
familiar pattern a thunderstorm explodes
into the atmosphere growing more intense
every minute the clouds begin to spin
and royal high in the sky they descend
closer to the ground still swirling
rapidly suddenly the rotation narrows
and intensifies
and touches down to earth
the question on everyone's mind is what
triggers that final step what makes the
tornado form so later on we go inside
that simulation and see where all the
winds are going how it's all structured
and of course the real thing is always
much better but with the simulation we
can go inside so in the last eight years
or so I've been working with a place
called the advanced visualization lab at
the National Center for supercomputing
applications at the University of
Illinois led by Donna Cox and we've been
visualizing these simulations not just
as illustrations but actually as part of
a story so the models that we're working
with our numerical models they
incorporate equations in this case
describing fluid dynamics fluid motions
cloud physics wind interactions and the
initial conditions are put in the
virtual storm does the whole thing by
itself so more and more of these codes
and the the data storage the computing
cycles are held in a kind of virtual
realm and institutions are all kind of
connected into it and so people from
far-flung locations can actually get in
and collaborate on visualizing and
analyzing the data so that's what
happened in this case there was a whole
lot of back and forth between scientists
and various places trying to answer that
question what's what's in that storm
that's going to cause that tornado and
that's kind of what the show became
about as well so we did this again with
a NSF sponsored project that included
something different which was a full
dome planetarium show and that show is
called black holes the other side of
infinity
and he was released last year and it's
completely different it gets projected
onto a 60-foot screen and it's an inside
of a dome and it's completely immersive
you see all your peripheral vision is
taken up and so this next clip is is a
simulation of the birth of a star in the
early universe and it was a really long
intensive collaboration with scientists
at the University of California San
Diego and it actually came out of a
monstrously huge simulation of the the
early universe hundreds of millions of
light-years across a huge area and this
was a little speck that they pulled out
and computed it at high resolution so
let's see scientists have recreated
these early times with supercomputer
simulations they can trace the long
steady process that formed galaxies from
the start gravity reigns in the cosmos
it draws together the primordial gases
these aren't gentle clouds as they grow
more and more dense they heat up
over millions of years they become hot
enough to ignite
the first stars are born
they end their lives in powerful
supernovae while their cause collapse
into black holes
this material along with a bunch of
other simulations was and visualizations
was also an ANOVA show called monster of
the Milky Way which was also funded by
NSF and it was on last year but the the
dome show was a real revelation so in
its first year it's been bouncing into
about 20 theaters around the world and
with an audience of about five to six
hundred thousand but the the great thing
is that the audiences are sitting right
there and they're not out there
somewhere and they seem to experience
the content very intensely and they're
in science museum context so they're
kind of there to learn something in the
beginning and these theaters are being
built around the world at a pretty good
clip so it's a really interesting kind
of a market so here's another clip and
this is based on Andrew Hamilton we
received Colorado and his attempt to
simulate with Einstein's equations what
a black hole is actually like and it got
much better in the Nova show but this is
still good the black hole pulls the gas
email then spews much of it back out now
things get really strange what you are
seeing is not the stuff of Hollywood
special effects it represents the first
time scientists have visualized a
journey into
their guide is Einstein and what his
equations tell them space here is so
warped the black hole acts like a giant
lens twisting the light that scatters
across it
at last we cross the event horizon the
point of no return but don't expect the
inside of the black hole to be dark
swirling with him as a maelstrom of
energy matter
hidden and the chaos is a single point
where the black holes mouse is packed
known as the singularity
you know the screen is as big as this
room so that's the amazing thing about
it we can we can put these digital
images on screens that big and really
blow people away and we can even like
make them sick return them during the
image too much but the accessibility of
the data means we can also think about
interacting with audiences in new ways
so as an example we're proposing another
dome show dealing with climate change
and it's also going to the NSF but the
partners are really interested in just
going ahead with it anyway so I think
it's just going to happen there's also a
TV project but it's kind of clear as we
look into that that the these times call
for strong global perspectives and these
dome shows like TV shows can really do
that but how do you make the global
perspective relevant to the local
perspective so let's see okay so so this
image here is a map of high temperatures
in June in two thousand the period
leading up to 2000 it's actually kind of
some dark spots over there that's kind
of Death Valley like conditions and 120
degrees is is about the average fine so
this is a simulation of a year to 2100
same time June the high temperatures
performed by a UK global climate model
and interpolated down so you can see the
dark red is much much bigger so you know
they say don't mess with Texas don't go
to Texas
this is this is where Death Valley is
new so our idea is to make you know data
like this much more accessible on a web
project so you can really kind of look
at the model results see how things are
going to work in your own neighborhoods
based on you know different scenarios
and we don't think that's on the web
right now it's kind of surprising but
there's another thing that we're
interested which is making it even more
local and there's a so there's one
effort which is in North Carolina that's
happening now where they're taking
climatic data and they're putting them
into portable domes inflatable domes
which are the big things scaled down
with smaller audiences and they're
starting to show climatic and
topographical data to people communities
and they're focusing on flooding and
storm surge right now but we're going to
see we're going to try to feed into that
and and even make it interactive as well
so just imagine you know the simulations
can be brought down and they are to a
smaller scale imagine being able to test
your own scenarios to simulate global
climates impact locally that could be
very impactful as well as very
educational so and there's one effort
that's doing that too to an extent and
that's the Hadley Center in Britain is
making PC sized climate models available
regionally around the world so for local
governments and scientists to plan than
to project out what's going to happen
right there we're almost out of time so